here's a Giant Pacific octopus in an
equally giant aquarium tank okay that's
all great for mom and dad and the whole
family who come to see the octopus
except there are sharks in this tank as
well sharks that are voracious predators
and opportunistic feeders and that have
been known to veer from their usual
fishy diets to munch on an occasional
octopus
these are spiny dogfish sharks did
anybody ask the octopus about this what
the aquarium folks are thinking is that
the octopus can use its ability to
camouflage itself as protection and if
that doesn't work it has the strength to
fight off the shark or at least dash to
the nearest hiding hole it can squeeze
into the aquarium folks soon realize
what does happen when you put these
sharks and octopi in the same tank and
you're about to see it too if you've got
the courage to keep watching if only
through your splayed fingers the octopus
not in the habit of attacking sharks the
shark sharp spines jutting out from its
dorsal fins that can puncture anything
that touches them the octopus can its
powers of defense save it in such tight
quarters the shark menacing on the prowl
just itching to use those rows of teeth
to crush its next meal I've got a
feeling this real-life version of Jaws
isn't going to be pretty and so the
shark
a shark boy am I glad I didn't have a
bet down on this match oh that's right
this is what happened the Giant Pacific
octopus as seen here in this amazing so
close you feel like you might get
squashed footage was making short work
of the shark in the tank
[Music]
dogfish carcasses kept showing up at the
bottom of the tank but you're seeing
this footage was taken to see what was
doing in these supposedly invincible
predators the aquarium staff learned
something new about the octopi there was
a danger in the tank all right but it
was all to the Sharks
[Music]
that's one way to defend yourself from a
predator eliminate them